if you're still playing titanfall 2
you've got new content coming your way
very soon I'm Tony and this is your
totally free gamespot news update the
new DLC is called a glitch in the
frontier and it includes two new maps
medium-sized glitch and deck which is
specifically for live fire mode the DLC
also adds a new faction the mrv n and a
new game mode called marked for death a
glitch in the frontier also allows
pilots to regenerate just like Call of
Duty's prestige option up to a new max
level of 100 but perhaps the most
important thing is that just like with
the previous DLC this expansion is a
hundred percent free to keep up with all
the upcoming titanfall 2 content be sure
to LIKE and subscribe a glitch in the
frontier comes to titanfall on all
platforms that's ps4 xbox one and pc on
april twenty fifth and there's still
more free content to come but for some
dlc shooting action right now you can
check out our live stream of Ghost Recon
wildlands narco road
[Music]
you